Charlie what's going on with you and
content what's your observation of the
social media landscape I think social
media especially Tick Tock as a platform
has changed a lot in what you see it's a
little bit more people's videos blowing
up one and then it kind of dying out a
little bit haven't seen too many people
get that kind of blow up everyone's
watching them for longer than like a
week or two what you're speaking to is
and this is why my career has been
yelling at the top of my lungs when
there's the moment to Glam grab
attention from four years earlier who
are still relevant you could have
sustained crazy growth you were in that
era where your one video went viral but
then it was like build build build build
build now every person on earth is
producing for the platform multiple
times a day and it's supply and demand
even though there's so much more
attention on Tick Tock than it was when
you started the amount of content has
outpaced that attention and the rise of
micro influencers